Salut ! Oh ! Il a changé de t-shirt !
Oui, je change de t-shirt quand je veux dans ces vidéos, vous avez vu...
des fois entre la réponse et l'énigme, des fois d'une vidéo à l'autre.
C'est free style au niveau t-shirt !
Alors comme tous les jours pendant 32 jours, cet été je vous donne une énigme.
Et chaque jour je vous donne la solution de l'énigme de la veille, donc on commence par ça aujourd'hui.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?!
Exactement !
Il faut aller la voir parce que là je donne la solution maintenant.
Alors quelle est la lettre qui vient après le S ?
Et bien c'est encore un autre S, après c'est un H, après c'est un N, après c'est un D, un O, un D, un T...
Pourquoi ? Parce que ce sont les premières lettres de 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, etc.
Ca n'avait rien à voir avec la position de la lettre dans l'alphabet.
C'est en fait la première lettre de chacun des chiffre dans l'ordre.
Ca aurait pu marcher d'ailleurs avec:
L, M, M, J...
Lundi, Mardi, Mercredi, Jeudi...
Ou avec les mois de l'année.
Ce n'est pas évident à trouver parce qu'il faut avoir un autre point de vue, mais quand on le trouve on fait
AAAH !!!
J'ai compris !
Et peut-être que ce sera la sensation que ça va vous donner en trouvant la solution de l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
C'est une question. Qu'est-ce qui est si fragile au point de mourir quand on prononce son nom ?
Je répète: Qu'est-ce qui est si fragile au point de mourir quand on prononce son nom ?
Cherchez bien, vous aurez la réponse demain, évidemment.
Si vous avez trouvé, vous pouvez mettre "j'ai trouvé" dans les commentaires et laisser un pouce en l'air.
Car les pouces en l'air, dans cette série de vidéos, nous servent à savoir le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la bonne réponse.
Profitez bien du soleil. Passez un bel été.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !